الطريق التي كانت تستغرق ما يقارب من ساعه
الى ساعه ونصف للوصول الى الاغوار
والتجمعات البدويه احتجنا اليوم لاكثر من
اربع ساعات ونصف طرق محفوفه
بالمخاطر كل ذلك تغير منذ السابع من
اكتوبر تمر الكهرباء والماء من حولهم
ولكنها للمستوطنات وليست
للفلسطينيين محاصرون في كتوت معزوله
يعودوا قادرين على كسب رزقهم مع اغلاق
الاراضي الرعويه كيف حالكم هون والله شو
حالنا هذا زفت ليش زفت من
المستوطنين الجيش يعني الحياه تغيرت معنا
كليا ايش يعني
انسنا انسنا من الحياه في ناس شردوا رحلوا
وانا ضليتني صام قلت والله لو بموت ما
برحل كانوا يعتاشون من الاغنام ومنتجاتها
اليوم بالكاد يتمكنون من حمايه انفسهم
واطفالهم صاروا يدخلوا علينا بالسلاح
وضربونا ويكسرو الاولاد الصغار والنسوان
البنات وبدم يطلعونا من ارضنا ومن بيتنا
بس على الفضي ما بيقدروا لانه هذا بيتنا
وارضنا وصاروا يدخلوا بالطيارات المصيره
يدخلوها جوا عنا على البيت وتصور كل شيء
ويهددون بالتهجير في الاغوار الشماليه
لوحدها اكثر من 30 تجمعا بدويا يعيش فيها
اكثر من 3000 فلسطيني مطوق باكثر من 17
مستوطنه وبؤر استيطان اضافه الى المواقع
العسكريه وفقا لمؤسسات دوليه زاد عنف
المستوطنين من ثلاثه اعتداءات يوميا الى
سبعه في اليوم
الواحد حكومه الاحتلال اعطت صلاحيات
للمستوطنين وخاص تسليح اغلب المستوطنين
الموجودين في ه المناطق واعطائهم صلاحيات
يمارسوا دور الجيش والشرطه وانهم استغلوا
هذا النفوذ اللي اعطتهم اياه حكومه
الاحتلال وانهم بلشوا يتعمدوا في
اعتداءاتهم وصبوا في حقدهم وكراهيتهم
وغضبهم اتجاه التجمعات الم موجوده هون انا
ما سويت
شي يحاول الاهالي توثيق الاعتداءات
بهواتفهم مساحه الاغوار الفلسطينيه تصل
الى مليون و100 الف دنم
يسيطر الاحتلال والمستوطنون على
82% من هذه المساحه وتؤكد مؤسسات دوليه
وفلسطينيه انه منذ السابع من اكتوبر تم
تهجير عشره تجمعات جوار بديريه الجزيره
الاغوار